welcome to this video this is the
highlights video from around seven of
the candidates in cantonment disc and
I'm trying to break records here for
speaking very very quickly very very
high speed because I've got four games
to cover in this highlights video and
they are all interesting really um I'm
trying trauma Bastion Villa and let's
get going we have a building defense
again very very solid as we all know but
it gets pretty sharp quickly we have
this set up this had been tried before
the tournament 97 a popular no idea that
let's black regroup the night to g6 and
get our money as position svitlana went
for age 3 here most natural move forever
and now honored comes up with the
naughty but probably it was a it was
found over the body took on d4 very
interesting after the you capture d5
white played fyf yeah he can sort of cop
out here with a move like this but this
is not why you play the whole the whole
setup if I've is logical but now 9h to
f4 and we see that those nights get to
really active on the King's side couple
of moves later after f6 black is even
trying to open up the F file and white
came under huge pressure Sevilla went
for a defensive set up with this now
here he had given up the bishop pal just
to try to yeah reduce why it's
initiative and at least he got some
active pieces here after the capture and
thought for a while because he has a
very tempting possibility and probably
the move that he should have played he
could have played rook takes f to him
very funny tactic
this is very clearly winning for black
but do I term can play the rupee eight
which after this kak might lead to a
position where white let's say after
this we'll get some compensation bishop
may be here look everyone I don't know
it's not it's not completely clear clear
cut at the end Island decided to play
Queen to first age six and then queen
here black couldn't play g5 to win
apiece as white can can sacrifice for a
big attack probably winning attack yeah
played this and now night h5 what has
really active pieces maybe he
underestimated that aren't after a
couple of more moves we see that this
idea is coming up here he decided to go
for a queen sacrifice took here and here
so it's got rook and Bishop for the
Queen and yeah well White has a
completely shattered structure like that
or what once a week so because of that
black has some fair compensation for the
Queen but he's not fighting for an
advantage anymore after some more moves
wyd managed to get the queenside opened
like that and we had some trades now
think Trilly I defended this very well
always being active and now after Bishop
c6 here he decided to just finish the
game by am sacrificing the exchange and
tm1 gaudiya even they greet to a draw
yeah white can easily defend the f3 porn
with with the Queen and black has no way
to make any progress yeah I think that
this is maybe a game well there were
some chances missed and especially here
I guess he should have he should have
done that nevertheless what gets a bit
of compensation but it's probably still
the way to go um it's maybe a bit of the
bit of a reason for that is that that
that I didn't play it is in such a
comfortable position with the tournament
littie probably feels you shouldn't risk
too much but yeah you must be cautious
with that approach if you play it save
all the time you also yeah um score less
em you need to risk the risks things and
maybe you still should have done that
here okay next game under akin to par
off to par off winner yesterday or day
before that beating kramnik so back on
fifty percent and in contention and
drinking on minus two let's see what
happens we get a Queens gambit and on
directing plays Bishop to g5 this early
Bishop move here which is yeah somewhat
headline of his he has played this
before against chrome Nick in Dortmund
2013 scoring a fine win after age six
this capture we get to the same position
here cromley cat played g6 last year at
the power of place now Bishop e7 and I
actually believe that this is a good
idea the position is basically
unexplored good good thing to note after
just a couple of moves that's not all 30
mins d preparation and yeah on Drake in
place Quincy to and III I'm not so sure
if this is great because I mean heck not
really suggest anything substantially
better maybe was g3 the thing is I
believe that black already has a very
comfortable position the power of plates
e5 he took a now 97 yeah and he will get
the porn back here and it's just very
active he took now on d5 and Drake ended
and here's he is a very important
position here to pawn off could have
played and pretty much a risk-free
position
with night xe5 which just leads to very
good compensation for black in case of
the capture this isn't fact I believe
quite risky with one key line being this
which leads to a good position for black
right probably shouldn't take here but
play a more conservative move like
Bishop e2 or something like that and
here try to block on d4 but it's a very
very comfortable position already for
black it's got two bishops everything
nice development is good Black is just
fine and this is the easy way to go but
to Paula plated in a much more
principled and a principle is the wrong
word but sharp wave he just recaptured
here and the still wants to take on c5
but in rights and raking to keep the
pawn which you did after a five and a
four b6 we come to a very very sharp
position now white cannot take this
opens all the floodgates not a good idea
he played c6 which is just stronger
tried to establish this very strong porn
on c6 get after this check white is
basically forced to move the king and
this is why Topalov went for this this
somewhat crazy looking set up with
allowing the pawn to c6 white cannot
really interpose here and empires
development even more you got to play
that 95 94 and now he played nine to e4
in fact I think here the polyp could
have gotten a pretty good game with
Bishop g4 and possibly 96 and Bishop c5
fighting for deform but he didn't do
that he played a very sharp 94 we should
be five-year you must keep this pawn
this is your trump card and he played I
guess simply a 40 plan he pushed with g5
directly trying to attack the night and
get to the f2
on the big problem is that even if he
manages to realize this idea it's not
really to his favor the h3 now plate and
h5 quickly played this is the the
consequence of g5 but look at that and
raking now just great king c1 and
basically ignore the g4 idea and the
problem is if black pushes g4 now going
to take and simply ignore it this is how
wide is plain king a two rogue d 2 g1
and white is going to be the one with
the decisive kingside attack you simply
it turned out that you simply cannot
play like that g4 is not playable and
this means you would simply have just
played those two moves and they render
to be completely useless as you cannot
use this g4 idea and what could just
consolidate now get the king vm look
into play everything nice and couple of
moves later we see that each form is the
killer move and that Apollo really was
lost after h5 g5 um here the problem is
you need to move your Jeep on and after
night f4 there's this threat and defy
the singing after kingi 895 he resigned
so to pull off with a very very tough
loss yeah against the tail end up under
akin and Reagan's first win so he climbs
from being down by two losses no win
just on minus one still it's not like
he's going to win the tournament but
good for him to have a win and for the
power of course it's it's a tragedy he
was back on fifty percent and had a good
game against Kramnik and now this this
really tough loss puts him back in 2-1
territory after seven rounds and this is
basically the end of his abisha I guess
I cannot really think
I cannot really believe that he will win
four games in a row or something and
then the second half of the tournament
especially considering that this kind of
game was really certainly a shocking
shocking loss all right this was under
akin to pull off let's go to kayaking
aronian kayaking it has lost one game
and didn't win anything yet so we need
to move at some point what I ronnian is
trailing Anand let's see ha again the
burden it's a plate so often yeah okay
but again we will get an interesting
game I promised you that put this on the
board quickly I owner aronian is playing
it a bit differently compared to Arnold
he's not playing the move d6 but
choosing the setup yantian why decided
to take on c6 um yeah I also could have
played like that this would lead to
something very similar to a two regular
ruler pass with a 60 knee not a bad
choice actually but he decided to take
and play a set up on the queenside I
believe that it does not be too much
really black looks we have black isn't
somewhat unharmonious position at the
moment like that you need to play
couldn't go f6 because chance the answer
it looks a bit weird with the Queen here
but the position is closed and black has
got enough time to set up a ammonius
position after d take c5 he went for
Bishop e6 with this fret so we got
simplification going and few moves later
we see that black has a slight
initiative he's got the ideas why term
can only react to that but it's a it's
not like right
is in big trouble but a comfortable
position for Aronian course yeah this
was a bit surprising for aronia and she
said in the press conference he had
expected why to retreat to have tools to
simply cover the c5 square so that c65
is not easily possible this in fact
looks like a very decent move after
Bishop f4 he was able to play c5 and
after D 596 there was some pressure on
the queenside now a couple of moves
later we see that here black has entered
on the queenside and it really gets a
bit tricky especially considering that
coyoacán was a bit down on time um after
c1h 6 h-4 night be too we enter a very
frosting stage now white plate see form
to defend against the threat here and
now Queen to disseminate here it gets a
very very sharp now night 2d three years
the big threat and kayaking now chooses
a tactical way to combat that place rook
be one okay to and Bishop to e3 yeah and
this invites night a form which was
played by Aronian and witches first side
looks really really great Knight c3 is a
threat bigfork and rook takes d2 and
kayak annette prepared this he gave up
on d to check and his compensation is
that he had entered with the rook for
counter plane and i have done some
analysis on on this in the in the longer
video and i really couldn't come to a
clear conclusion if black should win
this or if why it has enough plane to to
fight we see that all this is false
check check check yeah it's really
forced g3 cat and now this check and for
instance here my analysis obviously
computer-supported came to the
conclusion that King edge one should
draw for white surprisingly enough it
should be a draw I mean black can always
give those Perpetual's and I don't see a
win after 93 which is the most obvious
tribe check there is this coming and
this seems to be a draw check and give a
ton of checks but he won't find a check
made here and wider threatening Queen a5
check to to check made himself yeah
that's it stuff King ashwin it's
probably a row he played King age three
my d3 check here he went for rookie
eight and this move definitely loses I
think Quincy six had stole some
potential to fight sorry I'm screwing
this up right chance first the check and
then classics now queen e six check was
what Aronian had planned check and after
that white maybe can try to hang on if
he avoids the obvious move rook c8 which
indeed losses um but a move like that
might be a chance to to fight in the
game he played rook e8 probably it is
still very critical but it's clear that
this is definitely losing check check
and it took on b5 and now black has
everything covered this check only four
is covered by the knight c6 squares
covered for the Queen so after g-form
Quincy form and queen air for black was
even having the main threat so that why
it was forced to trade Queens and now
the queenside bones are too dangerous
and black bonnet in short order so very
very important game and
good game but Aronian who with the win
is on plus two we saw that on and played
the draw so they share first place with
plus two and will face each other of
course in round 8 with uronian having
white a really really crucial game to
look forward to and fro coyoacán thats
it hes on- to know when pretty miserable
tournament for his standard and
expectations okay still a game to cover
and this is also wild Kramnik
Mammadyarov okay we have the Rogozin
variation which mamedyarov had played
early and the gentleman and chronic is
going for an absolute main line of this
opening for example here we see that i'm
here there's also bishop a tree but
Bishop d7 s as mentioned a main line and
we are talking about the position that
both players had on the board earlier
chrome nick has played this with white
and black mamedyarov as well and the
curious thing is now are coming played
age for that mama drf now over the board
came up with beef IV for 30 minutes on
the smooth and it seems to be not too
great to be honest after a four white
got a nice structure on the queenside
with this very strong night maneuver
white has good harmony in his pieces he
doubled on the beef o very soon and
everything looks nice is an active
bishop here here everything's fine and
what can easily prepare his advanced but
chronic here decided to strike in the
center with default and this now leads
to crazy complications they are up late
night 26 and TM chronic decided to
the structure radically by taking on d5
90 x f4 and see takes a d take c 6 yeah
this is of course super strong see porn
but on the other hand black has an
important idea as well and this is g5
this Bishop is cut off and will be one
definitely white cannot save this piece
the point of course being that after
this white cannot check because of the
capture he played c7 rook 26 attacking
this and now white must give it up there
is no way to save it check this and d5
yeah I d5 a very important to keep the
night for me six yeah and this is of
course a crazy position white has two
pawns for his piece and this very
dangerous c7 pawn um it is absolutely
impossible to to show adequately what
was possible it's in this position in
this summary video I will point out some
important spots Bishop see 80 k f6 all
this seems to be fine and now look at ya
this some in fact allowed something here
Mammadyarov probably could have taken
with the night which leads to very good
winning chances but the line it's so
long after that it's hard for me to show
it's like that this here seems to this
idea seems to guarantee that white is at
least promoting but black will still
have a better position after that um
yeah you really must look at at the long
video it's no no way around that far for
this for these complications he took
with the rook and now why play d6
pushing the pawns yeah and Bishop g4 was
fine it seems that here the best move
was Luke d8 and should
ibly lead to a row which is how to
explain in like 20 seconds the thing is
that black check can play something like
that to to get this counter attack
against the king it probably will lead
to a draw something like that for
instance is a draw yeah which will be
shown in the in the rocker video he took
on yet and this is Kramnik too gone yet
and this should probably lose the game
as hard as it sounds the thing is there
check this is all fine brooke the eighth
and here in this position homage elf has
a very very narrow path to a win which
she manages to find almost check let's
see check took here and d7 yeah and the
big thing is that you have this check
check serious white cannot go here this
is losing do jack 96 you need to go here
and now the strong move / should be six
he finally found all that played it and
now kramnik played this this book check
the only plausible continuation the
problem was that something like that
check check Nate needs to mate the white
needs to check the any possible move and
here Mammadyarov absolutely shockingly
took on a fade which probably loses the
game even he should just go here and
after this check go to h6 and this is
winning like acids winning now because
this is a maid threat you said cannot
simply promote the only possible move is
this and after the check check you take
on these heaven and black wins you need
to take a moment to just realize it like
is winning here because this is a block
they both hang but there is no new phone
right something like that as a
relatively best and blank will win this
easily so after the rook check here he
should just play King g6 and win the
game instead he took it immediately GM
they promoted and here after King g7 in
fact King f7 would've still put up quite
some substantial resistance played King
GG seven though quickly and after Queen
B seven probably realized that the
intended Knight f3 check is now leading
to nothing white can just take it yeah
maybe you thought that he will actually
get the meat in here but Queen B 7 is
just protecting everything and d8 majors
of course are not made but promoting
with check is also threatened so he can
gave some chest by checks check check
and with this move resigned the game so
tragic outcome for Mama dro who played
excellently this complications and then
yeah strangely enough very quickly took
this and instead of winning the game
even lost it so a big big turnaround for
for the game and for the tournament just
imagine if wadiyar off would have won
the game he would be on +1 and right
behind are not and Aronian with all the
chances in the world and now he's out of
it basically being on minus one what
prom leg is the one who is still in the
tournament it could have easily went
strictly the other way around so very
dramatic round so and the video got a
bit longer but it even that was was so
brief that it was tough to to follow
what was happening in this kind of game
I mean you could easily do it to our
video on it if you want him and super
only don't have everything in it ok I
hope you enjoyed the quick summary make
sure to check the single-game videos if
you really want to see more of this hair
in complications like in in this game
all right I'll be back tomorrow to come
around eight with the all important game
aronian against Arnold thanks for
watching